تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قال
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
اليكوف في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره ان
بلاده لم تبدا هجومها المضاده بعد واضاف
ان الجيش الاوكراني في طور التحضير وان كل
جبهه ستكون لها مناوراتها الخاصه على حد
تعبيره حول ابرز ما جاء في المقابله ينضم
الينا من كيف مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج عمر
ما اهم ما جاء ايضا في مقابله روزنكوف
نعم محمود لعل من ابرز ما جاء في هذه
المقابله التصريح الذي قاله روزيكوف والذي
اشار الى ان اوكرانيا لم تتواصل مع اي طرف
من الاطراف خلال الصراع او خلال هذا
التمرد الذي حدث في روسيا الاسبوع الماضي
كما تعلم كان هناك تقارير تتحدث عن
محاولات للتواصل من قبل مؤسسه مجموعه قبل
هذا التمرد في عندما كانت المعارك مشتعله
في باخ متقاريس لوسائل الاعلاميه ولكن
الوزير قطع هذا الحديث وقال اننا لم
نتواصل مع اي طرف من الاطراف ايضا تحدث عن
سالناه عن نقطه مهمه وهي موضوع الصناعات
الدفاعيه والصناعات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه قال ان هذه الصناعه ستشهد قفزه
خلال الفتره المقبله وان اوكرانيا قادره
على على الصناعه الصناعات سواء صناعه
المسيرات او حتى صواريخ بعيده المدى
مستشهدا بان الصاروخ الذي دمر القارب
الحربي موسكو كان صاروخا اوكرانيا ايضا
كان يشير الى ان
الحلفاء قد اكدوا حلفاء اوكرانيا اكدوا
لها في كل المناسبات انها انهم ماضون مع
اوكرانيا حتى النهايه ومهما كلف الامر في
حربها مع روسيا يستند على هذه الوعود التي
اطلقت وكذلك لم يستبعد عن ان تكون
اوكرانيا ربما في فتره مقبله
عضوا في حلف شمال الاطلسي لانه قال انه
اوكرانيا اثبتت في كثير من المناسبات انها
الدرع الواقي والدرع الحامي لاوروبا من
الجهه الشرقيه كما ذكرتم كان هناك حديث
ايضا عن الهجوم المضاد الذي كثر التساؤل
عنه قال ان هذا الهجوم لما يبدا بعد كانت
هذه عباره عن مناورات قامت بها القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه وان هناك خططا لقياده
الاركان والجيش الاوكراني بهذا الصدد
لنستمع الى ما قاله حول هذه النقطه
بالتحديد
في هذه المرحله بالتحديد بالامكان القول
اننا ما نزال في مرحله الاعداد فقط قواتنا
المسلحه تقوم بتنفيذ بعض العمليات
والمناورات اضافه الى عمليات نزع للالغام
في مناطق وجبهات عده هم يقومون بالمهام
المنوطه بهم وفقا للخطه الموضوعه من رئاسه
الاركان وسنرى تطور ذلك كما اتمنى خلال
الايام القادمه
عمر الحاج بن كيف شكرا جزيلا لك